presque 3 ans après le début de
l'affaire jubilard qui a passionné les
Français les deux juges d'instruction
ont annoncé que leur enquête était
achevée son mari Cédric seul et unique
suspect dort toujours en prison
actuellement mais va faire une nouvelle
demande de remise en liberté son ancien
codétenu avec qui il avait fait de lourd
à qui il avait fait de Lourdes
révélations est avec nous ce soir pour
tout nous raconter et puis bien sûr il y
a de nouveaux éléments dans l'affaire on
n' pas pu les développer complètement
hier avec Michel Marie euh mais on va le
faire ce soir avec l'excellent euh qui
est avec nous il est excellent mais j'ai
voilà c'est ronand Folgoas je sais parce
qu'à chaque fois j'ai ronand j'en
connais pas beaucoup je suis
désolé pé disparu depuis décembre 2020
l'enquête pour retrouver Delphine
jubilard vient de connaître un coup
d'arrêt la justice vient d'annoncer la
fin de l'enquête dans le cadre de
l'affaire Delphine jubilar pourtant
l'affaire continue de connaître des
rebondissements il y avait des traces de
salive sur le pyjama qui portait la nuit
de la disparition mise en cause dans
cette affaire C jubilard Mar de
delphineour toujours clamer son
innocence malgré son incarcération mais
aujourd'hui Marco son ancien voisin de
cellule affirme que l'homme s'était
confié auprès de Lui l'enquête jubilar
fermé l'ancien codétenu de Cédric sort
du silence dans TPMP et fait de folles
révélations merci d'être avec nous merci
Renand c'est toujours un bonheur de vous
avoir parce que vous êtes excellent et
Marco est avec nous ancien codétenu de
Cédric jubilard merci à vous vous
connaissez ou pas on s'est déjà
rencontré une fois oui ou d'accord très
bien alors on va revenir sur tout ce qui
s'est passé et Renand est-ce que vous
pouvez nous reraconter pour nos
téléspectateurs à 20h56 en direct
l'affaire jubilard parce que on a
toujours pas retrouvé le corps ben en
quelques mots tout tout tout simplement
dphine jubilard qui est une maman de de
deux jeunes enfants qui avait 33 ans au
moment de sa disparition en décembre
2020 et bien a disparu justement la nuit
du 15 au 16 décembre 2020 à caniaac lesm
on est tout près d'Albi et euh et sans
laisser aucune trace elle a disparu on
n' pas retrouvé non plus son téléphone
et la dernière trace de vie qu'elle
qu'elle laisse derrière elle et bien
c'est un message qu'elle envoie à son
amant il est 22h55 ce ce 15 décembre
2020 puis elle a passé une soirée télé
avec avec son fils et pendant ce
temps-là et bien Cédric jubilard lui il
est parti selon sa version bien sûr il
est parti se coucher vers 22h30 et il
s'est réveillé dans la nuit vers 4h mo15
et là il constate la disparition de son
épouse c'est en tout cas la version
qu'il défend évidemment la la justice et
bien a tendance à ne pas vraiment le le
croire puisque après 6 mois d'enquête il
a été mis en examen donc on est en juin
2021 mise en examen pour le meurtre de
son épouse et depuis il est en en
détention provisoire à la à la prison de
de Toulouse se et et là il y a quelques
jours les juges d'instruction ont décidé
de de clore leurs investigations elles
ont envoyé un avis de fin d'instruction
manière de signifier bien que désormais
les recherches sur le terrain sont
terminées les expertises tout ça c'est
terminé les auditions aussi et que les
parties civil et la défense de céd
jubilard ont maintenant quelques
semaines pour faire des demandes d'actes
complémentaires qui pourraient prolonger
un petit peu le l'information judiciaire
mais on se dirige tout droit maintenant
vers vers un procès d'assise alors c'est
vrai que ça encore rebondit à Chile
cette affaire oui par quels sont les
nouveaux éléments Gilles et B c'est la
salive on a trouvé sur le pyjama que
portrait Cédric voilà c'est c'est le
nouvel élément qui peut déclencher de la
part des différentes parties de
nouvelles demandes d'expertise par
ailleurs que je voudrais parler moi des
notes de de Delphine voilà le le
récemment en juillet ont été révélé des
notes de Delphine c'est-à-dire que dans
ses sous-vêtements il y avait un petit
coin d'enveloppe où elle avait noté des
choses elle avait noté le nom et le
numéro d'un avocat elle avait noté
euh le calcul d'une pension alimentaire
elle avait noté le nom de son amant donc
les juges se demandent si Cédric
n'aurait pas découvert ses notes et si
c'est la découverte pares Cédric de ces
notes n'aurait pas peut-être donné lieu
au passage à l'acte voilà un élément qui
sera en tout cas versé au dossier euh
Marco vous êtes l'ancien codétenu de
Cédric jubilard
euh alors vous avez passé des heures à
converser avec Cédric jubilard à travers
les fenêtres de de cellules voisines euh
et combien de temps a duré votre vous
avez vous êtes resté euh à côté de lui
en cellule 3 mois 3 mois d'accord donc
c'est ouis c'est assez long près et vous
parlez très souvent tous les soirs tous
les soirs il vous a parlé direct non non
au début c'est personne se parle ouais
et après quoi vousz demander pourquoi il
était là même pas me l'a dit direct ouis
et alors
justement il vous a dit quoi par son
affaire que je connaissais pas du tout
ah vous connaissiez pas du tout
l'affaire arrivé du Portugal pas du tout
ah ouais ouais Interpol m'a ramené en
France d'accord et je suivais pas les
infos
médias on a fait connaissance par
rapport aux autres personnes que je
connaissais de là il a plus de confiance
à s'ouvrir est-ce que
euh votre but c'était de le faire avouer
ou pas du tout vous voulez discuter avec
vrai au début non c pour qu'il me laisse
tranquille je l'écouté 5 minutes après
j'allais me poser ouais quoi il parlait
beaucoup toute la nuit ah toute la nuit
ah ouais quand même
euh vous avez encore ces nouvelles ou
pas du tout non pas du tout il vous TR
avec la France ça ouais ça vous savez
même pas si vous en a voulu d'avoir
parleré après il s'en fout en plus pas
du tout c'est sûr que oui oh non il est
il est possible alors il faut il faut
dire quand même que que Marco a été
confronté à Cédric jubiler dans le dans
le cabinet des juges d'instruction
c'était je crois au mois de mai 2022 là
pendant plusieurs heures vous avez été
bah voilà mis mis mis en face l'un l'un
de l'autre et puis les juges ont essayer
de de et bien de de demander comment
c'est ce que Cédric jubilard pensait de
de vos révélations puisque vous aviez
expliqué notamment alors il va nous
expliquer alors justement parce que vous
aviez révélé que Cédric jubilard vous
avez avoué avoir tué sa femme ronté quoi
exactement débarrassé débarrassé alors
il vous a dit quoi il vous a dit je me
suis débarrassé de ma femme non il m'a
dit je suis dans ma chambre j'ai plus de
batterie dans mon téléphone je suis
parti au salon prend moi en chargeur
pendant ce moment-là j'ai vu que l'autre
connard lui a envoyé des messages donc
j'ai pété les plans et je m'en suis
débarrassé c'est ça donc c'était son
amant forcément donc voilà donc et euh
vous avez essayé d'en savoir plus sur
son récit oui vite fait peu à peu peu à
peu parce que c'est les vrai que par par
phase ouais que par phase après quand il
commence à fumer c'était ah il fumit des
ben oui ouais et donc là il balançait
tout il pe réfléchissait plus
euh vous avez cru tout de suite à son
récit ou vous pensiez qu'il était mytho
même pas je m'intéressa au début ouais
je m'intéress je l' laissé parler 1
heure 2h oui oui oui après je va me posé
et parce que est-ce que pour vous tout
ce qui enfin il pensz qu'il a s'est
vraiment débarrassé de sa femme ouie il
dit oui ouais vous vous avez pas de
doute non c'est pas mytho il a pas voulu
faire non il est pas mytho et très
intelligent ah ouais ouais vraiment très
intelligent j'en ai croisé beaucoup ah
des abrutis des intelligents des moyen
ouais lui ça va il est dans la norme
dans la norme ou il est un peu auudessus
non dans la norme des
intelligents dans une lettre adressé à à
Séverine sa nouvelle compagne il écrit
dans un message codé que vous êtes une
personne capable de les aider pourquoi
il a dit ça le passé mon passé ah c'est
ça ouais quoi les aider dans quoi vous
les aideer dans quoi en tout
c'està-dire je pe les aider à sortir de
la galère vous l'aidiez au placard ou
pas j'envoie fumer c'est pas aidé ouais
vous l'aiez pas du tout non non je
l'écouté je parlais avec lui c'est tout
ouant ouais je je crois que pour pour
pour bien comprendre et là vous
m'arrêtez Marco parce qu'il y a que vous
qui pouvez savoir mais ce que j'ai
compris de la dynamique de vos échanges
c'est que Cédric jubilard sait que vous
allez sortir de prison dans quelques
jours quelques semaines là là on est au
mois de septembre mois de septembre 2021
lui vient d'arriver en prison et ca il
découvre cet univers carcéral et et et
et vous êtes voisins de cellule vous ne
vous voyez jamais d'ailleurs parce que
l'un et l'autre sont à l'isolement donc
vous communiquez comme ça à travers les
les barreaux mais vous ne vous voyez
jamais physiquement et et là il compte
aussi sur vous pour faire passer un
message et pour faire le lien avec
Séverine qui qui est sa sa petite amie à
l'époque hein puisque désormais ce ce
n'est plus le cas mais il compte sur
vous pour faire passer un message qui
qui contournerait un peu le la justice
donc voilà une fois qu'on a dit ça bon
c'était quoi comment vous êtes rentré en
contact avec sine il m'a donné il m'a
écrit son adresse son numéro de
téléphone tout ouais il les a écrit de
ses mains et je sorti je l'ai appelé on
a marqué rendez-vous oui vous avez
révélé qu'elle vous avait donné les les
coordonnées GPS du lieu où Cédric aurait
enterré le corps de Delphine les photos
des amants les lieux euh m' m'a appelé
en direct du local mais mais Séverine
elle démon cette information elle est
enregistré moi j'ai transmis tous les
enregistrements au tribunal ouais non
mais disons que Séverine là encore
vous m'arrêtez elle a elle a un moment
elle a elle a fait un rapprochement
d'idée euh vous Marco vous lui avez dit
que Cédric vous avez parlé d'un endroit
qui avait brûlé et elle par association
d'idée pense à une ferme qui a brûlé sur
la commune de caniaakléine à un moment
où c'est vrai cédric est encore en
liberté là au printemps 2021 et par donc
cette association d'idée elle en vient à
vous dire bah peut-être que c'est là
mais elle-même Séverine en réalité n'en
sait rien parce qu'elle était placée
quand même en garde à vue c'est ça ça
était quand même une affaire dans
l'affaire là on est en fin d'année 2021
elle est placée en garde à vue Séverine
et elle elle est mise en cause pour
celle de cadavre on parle quand même de
ça et finalement elle sort de sa garde à
vue totalement libre parce que les
enquêteurs de la SR de la section de
recherche de Toulouse ont compris qu'en
réalité elle ne savait rien mais mais il
y a eu cette idée peut-être que elle
allait mettre enfin les enquêteurs sur
une bonne piste et cet endroit a été
fouillé pendant des semaines et et ils
n'ont rien trouvé malheureusement Marco
vous avez pas essayé savoir vous quand
vous étiez en vrai j'avais pas trop le
moi je partais le 25 il est arrivéal
ouais le 27 je me mariais je partais
plôt d'accord donc j'ai tiré la cor
jusquà où j'ai pu après ouais vous avez
pas pu savoir où était le corps de
Delphine malheureusement Marco vous vous
avez raconté que Cédric jubilard en
prison il jouit un peu les caïdes il
voulait être la star de la prison et
cetera pas caïd est-ce que un peu les
non mais un peu les les stars on est
d'accord là-dessus est-ce que il aurait
pu bidonné tout inventé pour vous faire
croire à vous qui étiez une personne
très connue dans la prison qu'il avait
des choses intéressantes à dire est-ce
que ça pourrait être complètement faux
ce qu' vous a raconé fa insulter du
matin au soir ah ouais donc il va pas
raconter quelque chose qui a pe il
l'ouvre la fenêtre fait insulter sa
maman il se faisait insulter tout le
temps matin midi et soir pourquoi pour
pourquoi mettezvous à la place des
personnes vous avez deux enfants qui ont
plus perdu leur mère et il font dans une
cellule Raon bien sûr bravo bah oui il a
Ron tous les mecs comme ça forcément au
placardûr ouais ouis il sont insulter
donc pour vous il vous a dit la vérité
oui parce qu'il me l'a écrit il m'a
envoyé des messages il les disait par
phase et la vérité on peut pas la
tromper le mensonge il revient à la
vérité mais la vérité il y a pas de r
point alors parce que lui Cédric jubé il
a démenti vous avoir raconté tout ça en
tout cas au premier degré il dit que
c'était non il a pas démenti jeai dit
dans le ton de la rigolate ça voilà
exactement oui ça dépend les mesures de
rigolade des personnes parle non
effectivement lui lui n'a pas n'a pas
contesté avoir tenu certains propos
après il dit il dit deux choses il dit
j'ai c'était sur le tour de la rigolade
et après Marco peut-être a extrapolé
certaines choses c'est c'est sa version
à lui c'est comme ça qu'il se défend et
et et après tout pourquoi pas je veux
dire on peut aussi imaginer que dans un
univers carcérale ou avec une
personnalité très narcissique comme
celle de C jubilard on s'invente une
chose pour pour ex aux yeux des autres
c'est possible c'est en tout cas la
ligne de défense qui est soutenue par
ses avocats ou Marco vous l'insultiez
vous au début non j'insulte pas
même pas ouis non pas du tout je parle
aux autres personnes mais vous disez
quoi aux autres détenus quand il
l'insula discutit diseit quoi dedans on
est en prison on est dans ouais mais
dehors on a une famille on a des amis on
a c'est dehors la vie c'est pas dedans
pour vous il y a aucun doute non c'est
lui c'est
vous allez sur de vous on dirait que
vous savez dir ouais vous avez vous avez
un truc vous savez un truc qu'on on sait
pas qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous a
dit de plus son des détecteurs C gar on
a parlé après quand on s'ouvre un ququun
on reconnaitt on voit à peu près la
personne on discute un jour 2 jours 3
jours quand on viit avec une personne
âge 24 il vous a raconté son histoire
vous a dit que sa femme avait pou tout
il vous a dit quoi les sous-vêtements
dans le lieu de travail c'est quoi ça
alors dit nous dans son lieu de travail
ils ont retrouvé des petites tenues qui
portaiit pas pour lui imp porte pour
l'autre connard
plein de petits mots au début il y a un
peu de faux au début ça ça modifie les
paroles mais après quand ça s'ouvre
quand il est plus relâché quand personne
l'insulte quand il est tranquille à la
fenêtre quand tout le monde s'entend
bien on essaie de donc il vous il vous a
raconté toute une histoire il vous a dit
que sa femme avait un amant c'est ça
l'homme le plus coquu de France ah oui
il vous a dit ça j'étais l'homme le plus
coocu de France je suis l'homme le plus
cocu de France si vous a dit il vous a
raconté éit quoi comme autre anecdote
euh que son fils il devait être appelé
comme mon le frère de mon deuxème prénom
plein de choses qui se lient à moi il
voulait m'offrir son chien ah ouais JECI
à la maison d'accord ah oua oui Ren
voulaz dire quelque chose non non mais
c'est vrai que Cédric jubilard est une
personnalité très étonnante très
déroutante et donc il est il est en
réalité il était en tout cas en
détention comme il
l'était en liberté pendant les 6 mois
dans pendant lesquels sa femme disparu
et il se présentait à l'époque comme le
mec le plus connu du Tarne il utilisait
toujours et régulièrement des
superlatifs pour pour pour parler de
lui-même bon voilà après c'est sa
manière d'être ça veut pas dire pour
autant que c'est un coupable à coup sû
mais il a une personnalité qui déroute
et qui risque si jamais il est renvoyé
devant une cour d'assis qui est quand
même le cas le plus probable qui risque
de dérouter sérieusement les les les
membres du du jury Pascal Marco vous
avez beaucoup parlé avec Cédric jubilard
il a effectivement beaucoup coup balader
les enquêteurs sa
personnalité vous la décriiez comment à
quoi à qui ressemble-il à quoi comment
il se comporte pardon basculé sur B
c'est c'est vachement non mais c'est
vachement important sa personnalité
c'est qui Cédric jubilard quelqu'un qui
a énormément confiance en Lui ouais ok
même si j'ai tort j'ai raison ouais
c'est ça et je vais le prouver ah ouais
vous avez pas prouvé che j'ai tort c'est
ça donc j'ai raison on parle souvent ici
des des multirécidivistes euh est-ce que
vous Marco vous vous dites moi je ferai
plus UNE connerie maintenant si je
serais en France j'aurais pas pas dire
je pourrais pas dire ça pourquoi parce
que on va pas dire c'est les amis mais
le cercle l'AMB l'ambiance l'environ le
donc donc non mais c'est très c'est
important ce que vous dites c'est fou ce
que vous dites ça veut dire que même
vous qui êtes vous étiez extrêmement
motivé à changer à tourner la page vous
avez une femme un enfant maintenant ou
des enfants vous avez combien d'enfants
j'ai une belle fille fille bien vous
dites les fréquentations et l'univers
dans lequel je vais me retrouver en
sortant ça peut me faire replonger donc
c'est c'est fou non mais c'est ça qui
est grave et donc c'est pour ça que vous
êtes partis ben ouais connais personne
je à zéro non mais c'est e c'est
incroyable les gars vraiment Marco je te
le dis ne fais plus e oublie tout
ça vraiment matin mi et soirà même le
dimanche d'accord tu fais quoi
maintenant je construis des piscines
d'accord bah très
bien non mais et après je plonge dedans
ouais mais va pas te noyer dedans quand
même euh non mais non non mais c'est
vrai Marco non mais Marco en tout cas il
faut que voilà tout ça c'est c'est c'est
très grave ce que tu as fait Marco je le
sais exactement non mais c'est vrai il
paraît c'est pourquoi on surnommé Cyril
Hanouna en prison hein pourquoi on
surnommé Cyril Hanouna en prison parce
que je ris tout le temps Mme maintenant
je r PNP quand ça arrive l'heure et les
gens t'appanouna ouais parce que chaque
fois que ça a commencé je leur demandé à
tous de se
taire donc
Choun il y AC la télé là-bas bah oui je
sais donc si ça crie bon maintenant tu
me regardes mais en liberté exactement
c'est allez je pens à toi et vraiment
Marco j'espère que tu vas pas retourner
dans faire des conneries non fini ça
fini ça fini fini complètement les mains
es sont déjà sacrifiées terminé on a
déjà connu c'est quoi dedans bon pass
bien non mais c'est vrai voilà tu es
heureux là tu es bien ouais avec moi
mais bien bah c'est mieux non c'est le
plus important ah bien sûr avant tu
étais avec beaucoup mais tu tu tutais
pas rien mais rien avec rien ah ouais tu
vois et tu tu tu dormais tranquille
avant en cellule oui non mais avant ah
non en cellule tu dors tranquille oui
mais avant avant tu dormais pas
tranquille non je dormais pas et
aujourd'hui tu dors tranquille à volonté
voilà tu vois vaut mieux avoir moins et
dormir tranquille exactement merci merci
en tout cas merci merci merci Marco
merci de la vi
merci